[Music]
this is an abc
podcast these are interesting times we
live in
when one of australia's most popular
media stars
is a maths teacher now some people love
maths for its elegance
and its sublime perfection but a lot of
people don't like it don't get it
and they're not interested in even
trying so how do we explain the
staggering
popularity of eddie wu who teaches maths
at cherrybrook
technology high school in sydney eddie
didn't even particularly like maths at
school
he felt like he was asked to memorize a
set of arbitrary rules
to a game he didn't understand or have
any desire to win
and he was going to be a history and
english teacher
but then he was persuaded to change his
mind and he's glad he did
then one day eddie decided to start
recording his classes
for the benefit of a student who was
seriously ill
the videos were strangely compelling and
so kids at his high school
started sharing them and then students
at other schools
started watching and then an
international audience
came flooding onto his youtube channel
which of course is called
wu-tube and now wahootube has nearly
700 000 subscribers
eddie was written several books for kids
and his most recent is eddie wu's
magical maths hello eddie richard thanks
for having me
you're in uganda not so long ago to talk
to
some teachers what brought you there my
relationship with uganda started when i
was sitting beside
an incredible woman at the university of
sydney her name is annabelle chauncey
and she and i are very similar in age
but
we're not similar at all in what we've
achieved in our lives because
as i'd met her uh 10 years prior she had
because of some work volunteering at the
un decided
finding herself in east africa that she
could do something about the dire
situation that so many young people find
themselves in an area like that she
realized this
education is the game changer for so
many communities
and families there and so in a
particularly rural area
of uganda so it's about an hour and a
half west of kampala the capital
she literally uh in the middle of the
forest
started up it's now three schools and uh
by chance meeting her
and sitting beside her at this award
ceremony we were both at we
pretty quickly realized we were both on
the same page and she said would you
like to fly over
and work with my teachers there and i
couldn't say no come to uganda
well and while you were there kids it's
an english-speaking country mostly
although there's some
there are older language african
languages there too uganda has its
history as a british protectorate which
is why
it's formal education system all of the
curriculums are
in english however the area that she
started her schools in they really it's
a like i said a
a farmland area most of the people who
live there are subsistence farmers
and so they're only speaking the local
dialect which is luganda
as opposed to people in the capital who
do speak english and i think a lot of
african nations share that
but that was part of reason why i could
be useful there because i could speak
the language of instruction
so that's just it what do you
know did you i mean did you know this
already that that there are universal
approaches to teaching because if you're
teaching a kid in the middle of
rural uganda as opposed to big city
sydney
is it basically the same thing or do you
have to sort of change quite a bit in
order to go
to somewhere like that it's really
interesting because i
knew i've always known every school that
i've gone to and now i've had the
privilege of going all around australia
and a few other countries as well
children are children
uh children their basic curiosity their
human needs for care support uh you know
trustworthy adults in an environment
that's stable all these things
that's right and and to have a teacher
who who brings energy and excitement to
their lessons
these are things which uh have nothing
to do with a particular culture
but at the same time i remember getting
closer and closer
to flying over to uganda and actually
spending tonight there and thinking
what have i got myself into and uh you
know the second you get off the plane
uh the smell is different all the signs
are different the language everything
there was a moment where i was kind of
terrified you know you got those
butterflies in the stomach but i thought
no
i'm going to go for this i'm here and
when you have that interaction
with kids and you can make eye contact
with them pose them a question make them
think
that's when i realized no no it's okay
remember your training everything came
back and it was
just like i was in any other school and
did they have questions for you
about who you were and where you were
from and why you were there well i think
there was
initially you know here's this person
from australia
and i think they have a picture in their
mind of what an australian looks like
and i was not it right it's a kangaroo
and a fishing cat
exactly that's right again you've got
the hat with the you know the corks
spinning around certainly they were
expecting someone who was caucasian
um but you know the second i opened my
mouth i think
uh i was nervous that i'd have to speak
a bit slower i'm the kind of person who
talks very fast especially when i get
excited about something
but they said to me and i was delighted
by this they said actually you're easier
to understand than some of the other
australian people we work with i thought
okay
i'm not sure why that is but i'll take
it uh there's a delight working there
so when you're teaching english so when
you're teaching math i should say
you say the key thing is to help kids
and people develop an idea of
mathematical fluency what do you mean by
mathematical fluency fluency is a word i
love it's something we borrowed from
linguistics of course
and it's this whole idea that when you
and i are having this conversation
right now because we're fluent in
english we don't really have to think
hard about what does this word mean what
does this phrase mean
it's something that is so deeply woven
into the way that we think
it's the language that we think in that
i don't have to
construct my sentence carefully all i
think about is what it is that i want to
convey to you
the emotion that i want to convey and
what i want to emphasize
and in terms of mathematics there are
these building blocks that are the same
you know times tables are something
which you want to be fluent in so that
you can then
free up your mind to think critically
and creatively
to solve a problem so they often say
maths is the language so it's like being
fluent in a language then essentially
where you don't have to
process every word of the sentence it's
just the the intent and feeling an idea
just comes out
with this language without having to use
your front of mind to process it that's
what you mean
absolutely and i think it's the same way
that a lot of people say oh i just never
never really understood mathematics it's
a little bit like saying well i never
really understood
spanish well okay if you're at a
beginning level where you're still
really just coming to terms with
what these words mean it's not the same
as having a conversation with someone
once you actually get a sense of that
or a musical instrument being able to
know where your fingers go how to get
that rhythm
once that foundation is there that's
when the creativity and imagination can
flow
and when you're trying to teach a kid
who's fallen well behind in maths where
do you start how do you how do you
figure out where to begin with that kid
well that question of where to
come back to really is the crucial
question all knowledge in mathematics is
so interconnected i think it's one of
the best things about it it's a bit like
a good story that you're reading when
you've got all these different
characters and
different arcs in the plot you think
where is this all going and what makes
good stories of the climax
everything of course the threads
reconnect mathematics is a bit like that
arithmetic geometry calculus
sometimes they look disparate but when
they reconnect it's when there's some
true beauty there that's
wonderful but it's also challenging you
miss one piece
and suddenly can you imagine for example
reading
a long set of books and taking out every
page about a particular character well
the whole story would fall apart
and so being able to say to a child okay
i understand you're having trouble
you're 14 years old you don't understand
trigonometry well probably
doesn't begin at the surface with
triangles and and angles and what have
you i've got to go way back
to fractions decimals percentages to
know where it is that you
had those gaps so that i can fill them
and then we can build from
from there so you've got to retrace the
footsteps of not understanding
exactly and then go to the point where
where the kid does understand
so because like times tables then gives
you fractions and fractions gives you
decimals and then decimals gives you
uh well and all that other stuff gives
you algebra and then you get
trigonometry so you have to go all the
way back sometimes to all the way back
to times tables i suppose you really do
and i think that a lot of people say oh
i could never come back
to mathematics you know i've closed that
door forever and i think part of why
is because you know we're trying to get
onto a train that's still in motion you
gotta get find a station
find a place you can connect to and then
you can get a board so
when you hear students say the problem
with masters doesn't have a real world
application
what do you say to that there's a sense
in which that's
true in a sense in which it's false um
the sense in which it's true is that
it's
a very fair criticism to say often we
learn mathematics in
very abstract ways we learn all these
x's and y's and
all these numbers and equations we solve
them and what do they have to do with
anything you know there's a classical
question of richard goes to the shops
and he buys 45 watermelons at 37 cents
each and
how much change did he get from a 50
note well
is that is that ever really something
that happened i'm sure richard enjoys
watermelon i'm sure you like that but
never bought that many
right not so many that would trouble me
exactly and you wouldn't even ask that
question you'd hand over the 50
and the cashier would work out the
change on a calculator
so there's a fair criticism to say it's
it's not real world it's not connected
to a context that makes sense to me and
so in
in response to that i would say look um
i am going to work really hard to be
able to show you
there are connections to whatever it is
that you're interested in you know here
we are
on the radio as our voices go into the
microphones that get converted into
electrical signals and head out into the
airwaves
there's mathematics fourier transforms
making all of that
possible so i've got to find the context
that makes sense to you before i connect
to the maths
but then the second thing i would say
the second
sort of response is that that's not a
fair criticism because
there are lots of things we learned
which don't necessarily have to have
a practical application i was talking
very briefly before about music
we have our children learn music at
school it's compulsory in primary and
for
a ways into secondary school you can do
lots of things with music music can be
practical you can
sell a product you can summon an army
into war you can stir up national pride
so music can be practical but i don't
think that's the reason
that we make everyone learn music we
make them learn it so that they can
appreciate this cultural
expression of humanity and make your
head grow a little bit absolutely yeah
it makes it makes it makes life worth
living actually those sort of things
i haven't told my kids that the thing
you need maths for is to teach you to
think methodically
to proceed in a linear basis like if
that is true then this can be true and
then that is true and then that is true
and then you get to the end of the
problem
teaches you problem solving doesn't it
that's the thing mathematical thinking
is all about
logic and there a lot of people say i
never use maths
you know day to day i just well any time
you want to think about
like you said a deductive process you
want to reason through something come to
a conclusion and know that it makes
sense
prove that something is the best way to
the best path through a situation
you're doing mathematical thinking you
like geometry particularly
why geometry is probably my favorite
mathematical topic even though it's hard
to choose one because they're so
interconnected but i love it because of
this
visceral experience that every human
being has when they see
something and literally a visual appears
in front of them
that gives them a sort of experience of
why something mathematical and logical
and patterned
not only makes sense but it's beautiful
as an example in in my book one of the
favorite things that i've gotten there
is this little feature about snowflakes
and snowflakes there's a there's about
uh a billion snowflakes
in one kilogram of snow and every single
one
of those snowflakes is different is
unique and yet they share
this symmetry this six-fold rotational
symmetry
that they all have despite how different
they are
and when you look at a snowflake under a
microscope for the first time
it literally takes your breath away i've
never shown a snowflake to someone
and then not just be arrested by its
beauty
and so i think geometry as a part of
mathematics which you know there's a
reason why our visual cortex is so
enormous in the human brain
it's something that speaks deeply to our
souls about
what the universe is about and why it
makes sense and when you see a pile of
snow
it's just like a lump of slush isn't it
but
you're breaking it down to individual
snowflake you see something structural
and beautiful and
symmetrical as you say i just was
reading a story about johannes kepler
the great
uh renaissance uh mathematician and
astronomer who sort of uncovered the
secret of planetary motion
who was fascinated by a snowflake that
landed on his sleeve while he was
walking across the charles bridge in
prague and he studied the snowflake and
looked at it and looked at it and
wondered what
its connection was to the number six
because it's six-sided and he looked at
honeycombs
in in beehives and wondered why that was
special there was something
beautiful about nature so so much of
madison seems to be about looking for
patterns in things that aren't
immediately apparent is that right the
german mathematician
carl friedrich gauss he said that
mathematics is about
thinking deeply about simple things
a snowflake that lands on your sleeve to
to sort of
take that and investigate it and you
know like you said this this six-fold
symmetry it comes from the
shape of a water molecule h2o two
hydrogen
one oxygen those two hydrogens attach
onto that oxygen
atom at 120 degrees that's the angle
that they form and if you
rotate that around three ways that's a
hexagon that you get and this
foundational tiny imperceptible
geometric shape
gives us all of this beauty around the
world how lovely
you're you're the child of uh chinese
malay malaysian migrants to australia
what
brought your parents to australia want
to come here eddie my parents
came to australia in the 70s
and it was really flowing out of the
fact that firstly they themselves
were the children of migrants so uh my
dad's
parents they were from china and they
left there in the
probably in the in the teens in between
the 10s and the 20s all right
and and they let they fled there in in
civil in the midst of civil war
incredibly violent time they left there
seeking a better life and knowing that
you know uprooting your entire
expectation and sort of all of your
relationships is worth it
for the sake of going somewhere where
there is where there's peace where there
is is prosperity where there is
education schooling and education was
certainly what brought my parents from
malaysia
to australia not being of actually
malaysian ethnic
descent uh was challenging for a variety
of reasons
yeah they've got those laws there don't
they which favor um
ethnic malays over chinese and indian
population
it's part of the uh the cultural
decision that they've made as a nation
it sets them apart for example from
singapore which is right next to them
and
you know ethnically very similar you
know proportions but
a whole different philosophy underneath
how the society works
and so them coming to australia was to
say look we know that our children
my brother my sister and i who were all
born in australia they're going to have
access to a life that was impossible in
malaysia particularly through education
through the employment we'd be able to
gain access to that's why they came here
so they would have arrived as part of
the first wave of
asian migrants to australia once the
white australia policy was
done away with once and for all they
must have had a rough welcome when they
got here in the 70s i've heard similar
stories
some parts of it were good other parts
not so good yeah it was uh
patchy to say the least i know that um
you know for starters i think
you know you you out yourself even
though my both my parents were fluent
speakers of
english their accent kind of stood out
and it was sort of
you can't go anywhere and open your
mouth without kind of declaring
i i don't come from here i'm a foreigner
and i've sort of brought with me
all of these things which frankly people
in australian culture were afraid of
and there was this great amount of
cynicism and fear about
what what does this um descent of all of
these uh
you know hundreds and thousands of
people from another country with all
their values and all of their
delicious food oh yes to be bad they're
delicious food but i don't think there's
an appreciation back then
of that part of their culture so i get
why there was that yeah that
apprehension i think it's just natural
human nature
your family would have been quite well
to do in malaysia as it was in kl back
back then
how was it for them to step down in
terms of standard of living and social
status by migrating to australia yeah it
was a big
step um and it was uh you know number
one it was financially so they came here
uh you know my dad was you know very
young he was 19 years old when he landed
here in australia
and i didn't have much except for the
sherman's back and a bit of support to
find a place to live get his studies and
what have you um so in addition to that
financial struggle and i certainly
remember growing up we we tightened our
belts we didn't have a lot growing up
but we didn't mind that we knew we were
in a wonderful and
beautiful country but it was also all
that social isolation you know uh
classically uh eastern cultures you have
many generations within your own
household
yeah and personalities nearby yeah
that's right and that was a real
uh gut-wrenching thing for them in terms
of raising their children it was a big
hit for my mom who entirely left her
career behind
because there was not this big extended
family around us that would have
permitted her to continue working yeah
your mum had been a journalist
in in malaysia were you aware of that
growing up growing up i had
no idea she was just mom who did a big
load of washing every single day for the
five of us
and was a uh absolutely a very uh
established well
you know skilled cook that was who she
was to me growing up i didn't know
until oh i was late in my teens about my
early
20s actually um finding that out about
her yeah she was a news reader
man and and how did she talk about did
she talk about that at all with you
not a word she was one of the things
about her was how
understated and humble she was about
everything
um in some ways that made her fit in
pretty well with australian culture she
never
blew her own horn about that in fact it
wasn't even from her it's from my dad
and then i asked her
um in the final years of her life about
that she told me a few stories here and
there but it was never
she didn't feel bad that that was
something she left behind it was a very
deliberate and conscious sacrifice that
she made for our sex
and how was it with you did you have
that kind of classic migrant situation
where the parents just let it be known
just quietly that they've sacrificed an
enormous amount
to actually bring you to this fine
country and therefore you are expected
to work incredibly hard
did you get all that i think i was the
youngest of three and so by the time
that i
came around it was i deeply internalized
how much of a look where we're here a
great
price has been paid for us to be here in
this country
and i didn't have to have anyone tell me
you'd better work hard to use these
opportunities
it was it was an assumption i made of
myself that this is something which many
people
don't have the privilege of enjoying so
make the most of it
you didn't much like primary school did
you eddie primary school was not a fun
experience
for me honestly i'm repressing most of
my memories
from when i was young because you know
coming off the back of
uh this sort of latent i mean
the phrase that got used back then was
every day but i really dislike
that phrase because it sort of makes
everyday racism sound like something
it's just
normal and casual it was every day and
that it happened all the time but there
was nothing
casual about it and so you didn't know
yeah uh
i was i am and was small so it was easy
uh
to to make proud me if you were a bigger
student which every single student was
um and that was kind of a i look back
especially from the viewpoint now as a
teacher
looking at students i've seen who you
know they they will take this out
on other students partly as a function
of their own experience of weakness so i
understand i don't hold that against
them
but it was it was not an enjoyable
experience and for many many days and
weeks i would
beg my mum to let me stay home from
school the new south wales state school
system has this these oc
classes opportunity classes for bright
kids and
and you were admitted to one of those
uh the final years of primary school did
that change things for you
it was the first moment in i guess i
would have been 10 years old where i
thought to myself
oh there are other people like me
having this experience firstly of being
a migrant child
the very small number of times i went
back to malaysia i
could understand cantonese which was the
language that most of my family spoke
but i couldn't
say it back in fact sometimes even now
if we're in a
chinese restaurant if i'm the what i
like to call the ranking asian i can i
can speak
the chinese the best out of badly but
the best out of the people who are here
when i order the dishes the waiter or
waitress will often
after i say a dish they'll say it back
to me
but with the correct intonation i'll say
look i already knew that i was saying it
wrong but now you
i know that you know that i'm saying
wrong thanks for establishing that my
wife has had exactly the same experience
being the ranking agent at the table a
few times you usually get that where a
hand looking around
okay it's me i'm ordering shell or
something like that exactly it's like
well it's my turn to speak so i knew
when i was back in malaysia i didn't
belong
in australia i didn't belong but when in
this opportunity class i was surrounded
by people who loved
learning i thought ah i've sort of found
my people and that was wonderful
tell me how your family was brought into
the life of the local church
in your area it started off in a fairly
uh innocuous way i think my
dad brought us along i think he thought
you know australia broadly speaking
has this you know uh uh christian
background
to it you know they pray in parliament
uh it's it's sort of the values that
um started australia as a nation
and he also had some friends who had
their same southeast asian background
it's like well let's come together
so there's that social aspect to it and
growing up i went to sunday school
but it was really probably my brother
actually so my brother is eight years
older than me and kevin
i viewed really as such a such a mentor
i had a very close relation i always had
a very close relationship with him
especially growing up i looked up to him
he
had never told me anything that was
untrue before
and he laid out you know here's what the
gospel is here's how it all works here's
what the bible means and i thought
well that that makes sense of life and
so probably from age seven
is when that kind of became part of my
identity and our identity as a family
so you went to a selective high school
was that would have been a good fit for
you as well was it more competitive
though eddie
it was certainly more competitive i
remember you know that sense of
being first from okay i'm one of the
smart kids
and then becoming a small fish in a very
large pond and i
still recall looking at some of my peers
who i didn't know at the time and
you know somewhat looking down my nose
and thinking i'm smarter than a whole
bunch of these kids and
rapidly being humbled and having to come
to terms with the fact that oh
i'm distinctly average in this place um
i didn't feel
i mean my identity didn't come from i'm
the top-ranking kid so it shook me up a
little bit but i was like okay
cool did you feel you failed at being a
nerd
i mean i i definitely got a sense that
all right here i am i found my
my place in the nerd pecking order which
was lowered down than i thought it
before
um but no i i just adored being around
such
smart you know thoughtful people i
really found a lot of friends there
what did you get from doing drama were
you introverted and did you find drama
to be
a way of dealing with that i i was
and remain um heavily introverted it's
tricky as a teacher because when you are
in the classroom a huge part of your job
is to develop relationships lots of them
very fast as well
and then of course standing up in front
of a large group of people communicating
to them verbally visually all the rest
so you develop a whole bunch of
traditionally extroverted skills but
drama
back at school i started it in year 9
took it all the way through to
my hsc the end of year 12. um those four
years of drama were hugely formative for
me and their skills i use
every single day how did you decide on
becoming a teacher then
i think it was from my experience first
of loving learning and loving to see
other people learn i i actually in the
first place didn't want to become
a teacher i think as probably a six or
seven year old wanted to become a
firefighter
then discovered that having chronic
aspect is not a good thing to have as a
firefighter and then you wanted to be a
dinosaur
yeah that's right i went through those
classics um but
i i sort of for the longest time did
actually want to go into it my brother
was studied computer science and then
the dot-com crash happened
and that made me reinvestigate and i
thought i love learning i love helping
other people learn
if i could have the opportunity to do
that for my life for my career
that'd be a pretty good gig you say you
like to see people learning
see does that look like something what
is that any facial expression what does
that look like it is i mean well it's
it's
it's that look in someone's eyes when
they suddenly
have this realization this epiphany
they're like ah it all makes sense it
all clicks
i've gone from that place where i'm
trying to do mental gymnastics and
suddenly it all coalesces in your brain
it's a pretty wonderful thing to observe
and does that happen to collectively
does it
do does the whole classroom go oh like
that or do they or does it like pop pop
pop
there's both there's both and sometimes
there's a sound to it sometimes i'll
hear people
draw breath or they'll say that
and hearing that is immensely satisfying
for me is that relief
as well that sound that sounds like oh
thank god i get it
there is that but there's also there's a
sense of wonder i think mathematics is
full of things
that explain the experiences we see
around us
all the time but don't have a reason for
why like why rainbows are right or why
snowflakes
have that symmetry it's something i
never tire of explaining
[Music]
on abc radio
you're listening to conversations
with richard feidler
podcast broadcast
online
[Music]
what did your parents think when you
said you wanted to be a teacher
i think at first they didn't say
anything because they were
speechless it really came out of left
field for them i think for a long time
they saw me
growing up watching my brother like i
said sort of fitting into that i.t
geek sort of niche pretty happily and i
think
they were surprised because i guess and
this is one of my joys as a teacher
i often get to see an aspect of a
student a child
more so and more deeply more
transparently than even their own family
does and so i my parents didn't see me
at school
as an army cadet helping a younger
student a recruit
learn how to pitch a tent or navigate
through the hills they didn't see me
as a peer support leader as a year 11
kid helping these sevens
make friends navigate their way around
the school these are really foundation
for my
joy in helping others learn and so i
think they were quite surprised and
taken aback
how old were you when your mum got
seriously ill eddie
i was in year 10 i can't remember now
which part of the year it was in so i
was either 15 or 16 years old
and it was it just took us all
completely
by surprise my mum always was a very
healthy
sort of person didn't smoke um was was
fit
uh cooked really healthy food so it was
kind of like what where did this come
from
was it was it a terminal prognosis right
right from the start so
she was given a number of months six
seven
eight months to live and this was back
in 2001
when i mean we'd come a long way but
certainly back then as compared to now
cancer was just kind of it was a big
word you heard the word cancer and you
thought
whoa this has just changed and redefined
everything about our lives
she was a fighter and this was lung
cancer and she'd not been a smoker at
all
and and there are it's actually um still
still not that well known that there's
this
many forms of lung cancer that will
affect people who have
never taken a cigarette in their life
how long did she hang on for
it was three years by the end and that
was that was grueling i mean she
she really wanted to hold on she she
held on long enough to see me
uh finish high school to see my my
sister get
married um but by the end even though
you know
watching her life sort of um vanish away
was was gut-wrenching but it was almost
also i mean my primary
emotional memory of that time
particularly i remember my dad was
actually
with my mum in palliative care and he
was staying there every night and
the doctors had told him you know you
should hang around this time don't don't
go home
my brother and sister and i were at home
and it was early in the morning it was
still dark
when my dad called our home
gave us the news and we just kind of
stood there the three of us
in in the in this fluorescent light of
the kitchen
with with the dark outside and just the
peak sort of emotion was really relief
she'd been through so much
at that point and just to know her
suffering had ended
that was kind of this big after three
years
we were glad to be able to say she's in
a better place
i can't imagine what that's like to hear
that when you're in year 10 it must have
been like the floor
falling away from you to some degree you
must have felt
like you needed to hang on to something
for dear life it was
a strange experience for me as
a year 10 student not having had
any friends again you know being here in
australia not having that extended
family and so therefore perhaps an
auntie an uncle or a cousin or something
like that had gone through this
so it was it was very new but in some
ways
for me at least it came at a time in my
life where you know
you're an adolescent you're trying to
find your own identity and you're trying
to
do that through you know your peer
networks at school and what you enjoy
doing and it sort of came to me because
my mom was very insistent she didn't
want
anyone apart from the bare necessities
she didn't want anyone at school to know
why i think there was this sense of
number one
she didn't want my brother sister and i
to be
that that kid whose mom has cancer i
think she viewed this stigma around it
um that she didn't want and she didn't
want to rely on other people
um she didn't want to put the burden of
of care
onto other people and she was also a
very private person you know
and so not not a single one of my
friends what about teachers did school
know what you were going a small number
of
my teachers knew so so the principal the
deputy the head of welfare
and um i i really leaned hard on those
teachers um
because you know i would sometimes turn
up to school and i'd just be
um ragged bags under my eyes because my
my mom's lung cancer as she
gradually lost lung function she
eventually got to the point where she
was
24 7 on an oxygen tank and in the middle
of the night uh
if she needed her oxygen tank changed um
you know my brother was working my
sister was going through her dentistry
degree
really i was the best suited person to
do that so i'd turn up at school
the next day having had very little
sleep and i'd just crash i would just
sleep in the sickbay for hours or even
fall asleep in class and to know that
they
they understood that my friends didn't
they didn't i just thought i was bored
with glass i guess
but school supported me through that in
the best way that they could
tell me what your advisor told you
because i'm i'm guessing your school
marks went went through the floor to
some degree there and
what kind of advice did you get yeah uh
my
my teachers did a great job as best as
they could anyway in the circumstances
supporting me
um not just by you know giving me the
structures and providing me
time and all that but that emotional
support so my my your advisor
uh still still a friend actually because
sometimes i go back to my old school and
say hi
uh mr flood he looked after us all the
way through the six years and i still
remember
in my hsc year you know this is the time
year 12
things count now every single exam that
you do every assignment that you hand in
it matters and i still remember there's
one task i had to do
i had to make a uh a mask so in drama we
had to craft a mask for ourselves
um and and color it all these layers and
i
it was terrible it was i don't think i
even got you know one out of ten
and i just kind of was gutted by how i
just saw my education
going down the drain and i knew like i
said from an early age
that education was why my parents had
come to australia in the first place
and i remember mr flood saying to me
you know after one of these moments
where an exam or an assignment just gone
terribly he said look eddie
it's hard for you to accept and believe
what i'm about to tell you
but i want you to just take what i'm
about to say and put in your back pocket
and remember it
which i still do he said look i've been
teaching for a long time
and you know every kid is different
every student i've ever encountered has
a different personality different
background
but i've i've met kids like you eddie
and i know enough about you i've seen
your character and your personality and
the the way you've approached
your life and your studies and what's
happening your family right now
and i want to tell you now i can assure
you whatever it is you're going to do in
life
you're going to be successful you're
going to make a difference you're going
to do something important in the world
and i know it doesn't look like it i
know it looks like your final exams are
going to go
you know terribly but i can see enough
about who you are as a person
on the inside that these circumstances
they're going to fall off of you one day
and you've got to have that faith that
this is going to come good there's light
at the end of the tunnel
so you did remember that and obviously
you're telling it to me now it's
something you you really did
internalize that do you give similar
speeches to other kids going through
hard times now
it's actually one of the main reasons i
remember that conversation so clearly is
because
i have now rehearsed versions of that
conversation with so many students
and looking at a student in tears just
emotionally deflated something's
happened to them either within school or
within their home
and when you're young you don't have the
benefit of
this perspective i mean you know i i
cross the road and i say to my kids hold
my hand when we're crossing the road
because you
don't have the peripheral vision to see
these cars that might hit you as we're
going across the zebra crossing
hold on to me because i can see
something you can't
i can see something about you that you
yourself can't see
and so it's in having the privilege of
talking to students over and over again
and having
the opportunity to assure them and say
you're on a trajectory
there's a part of you that is not
defined
by your circumstances and actually the
circumstances of anything they're going
to make you stronger
and i don't want you to lose hope i
don't want you to give up that's a
lovely thing to say to kids
what you were going through at the time
seems horribly unfair i don't know if
unfair is the right word for it eddie
but it's awful it's always it was awful
for you
as a kid now your church has a lot to
say about suffering
do you think about that a lot did you
talk about that a lot in your church
yeah yeah we did i mean i i'd probably
say
it was that bedrock of knowing
from from the bible as a christian that
uh
one of the most important things in what
christians believes is that god is god
is sovereign he has
control things don't happen by accident
and
so even though from one angle you might
say well
you know there are terrible things
happening god why are you doing this
to me at the same time i know just from
the distance from me to my kids i
will frequently put my children through
things they do not want to do
i will hold them down as they fight and
kick as
a doctor or a nurse punctures their skin
with a needle
and immunizes them from all these
diseases and i'll say
you don't want this but this is what you
need
and to know that if that's the way i
regard my children if god is so much
wiser than i am
compared to me to my children i know
that what i'm going through if it's
my my mom being torn away from me or
these experiences of being younger and
and being treated in these harsh
and and cruel ways uh those things
shaped me and formed me and they've made
me who i am today
i said right at the start that you
weren't going to be a maths teacher you
were going to be an english and history
teacher
so why did you change your mind i know
in a sense it might look like
it's left and right like a watershed
moment almost heading in opposite
directions
but for me the reason i became a teacher
in the first place was really about
this wonderful opportunity you can have
to to interface with a child's
life in fact you know i said before that
as a teacher i often get to see
children in a light that their own
parents don't even get to see
and over the years six years you get
with a child you might not be their
teacher every year but you have this
ongoing relationship with them and this
ability to
to influence and shape and and and
launch off this child into the world
and give them equip them with the skills
and the disposition and the outlook on
life to make a positive difference in
the world
that's something you can do from every
subject in fact every subject does it
in its own way equips children with
skills and perspectives that they can
use to make the world
better right so it says there's the
maths is a big deal but it's really the
teaching
it's the it's the teaching that's the
teaching and the mental child you get to
interact with so literally
if you said to me as i left here um
eddie you know what the department's
just my decision
you're going to have to be an art
teacher um i probably would not be a
very good art teacher i couldn't paint
my way out of a paper bag
but you'd have a red hot go oh
absolutely because i know
the visual arts every different thing
that we have our children learn
equips them and makes them better and
that's a wonderful privilege so why
maths then how were you persuaded to go
into maths
the thing that the particular thing that
drew me into mathematics
was really about need i i saw
uh going out into university that there
weren't enough mathematics teachers they
still aren't this is more than 15 years
ago that this
trend existed in new south wales across
australia
the western world really we don't have
enough mathematics teachers because if
you're
any good at mathematics you'll you could
become an engineer or an actuary go in
finance
earn a lot more money have better status
in society
and so mathematics education has always
struggled to have the right people in
there
and i thought look if this is where the
area of need is
if this is where society has a gap that
needs to be filled
and if i can do something to contribute
to that actually that made a lot of
sense to me
you know i don't think i was even aware
this was a problem that there's a
shortage of
skilled math teachers at the moment i
didn't know when i was at school either
because all of the teachers
whom i had particularly you know in a in
a lovely
well-served metropolitan area of sydney
you're going to have
lots to grab from lots of trained math
teachers who have a degree but then
as you go into other areas that are
harder to start particularly as you go
into rural regional remote
for every school like the one i went to
where all the teachers were maths
trained you've got a school where
there's
no maths trained teachers we've got
people who are out of field they're
doing the very best they can we're very
grateful for them
but they don't have nearly support they
need and so it was something i only
discovered when i got to university
once you were a student teacher did the
kids smell your fear
i i can remember student teachers really
well we could smell the fear coming off
most of them when they walk into the
classroom without a doubt
i still remember back to when i was a
student teacher and
i was i was a nervous wreck during those
you know i'd have a three week and then
a five-week placement
and i remember coming back to uni
sitting in
you know a lecturer hall or a tutorial
space
and thinking oh thank god i'm not
responsible for what's about to happen
for the next hour
i don't have to have a lesson plan that
could go well or disastrously
i definitely early on took a while to
find my feet my
sort of persona as a teacher you had to
learn all these skills that didn't come
naturally like
how to be angry i mean anger comes
naturally to some teachers but didn't
come naturally to me well
in my day young man it used to be the
teacher would simply be angry by pinging
a little bit of chalk at your head
that's right i've had a gut full of you
fired look
great that was a very good first
impression i can tell you in the head
with a piece of chalk
i i still remember a woman who i met
out in the riverina she must've been 75
or 80 years old and she said when
we got asked to do a maths problem we
would be instructed to write the answer
to that problem on our hand
then the teacher after a few minutes say
hold up your answers so i can see them
on your hands
and then that teacher would go to the
front of the room she would open the
drawer
out of her desk and she would pull out
her cane
and any student who had the wrong answer
written on their hands they never forgot
for the rest of their lives as this
woman didn't
thankfully we don't do that anymore no
that's a bad thing that's a bad thing
but uh you have to have other ways to
earn the respect of you especially in
high school
how do you how do you do that do you do
you simmer do you look do you do you
raise your voice or do you go quiet
you've got to have the whole set of
tools in your toolbox
um one of the things which i realized as
a teacher you know you're trying to
explain an idea a concept a skill and it
doesn't cut it
to know it well enough to answer those
questions in the textbook and then you
go into the room and then you just tell
the kids
what you know one way is not enough you
need
15 different ways to approach an idea
and it's the same with
classroom student discipline knowing
what it is every kid brings their own
cultural and and family baggage and i
remember
one of my old supervisors he said 99 of
the problems you have in your classroom
they started outside your classroom so
you've got to know the kids know what
they're going through and give them
what's appropriate to them oh that's
psychology then absolutely right
so you say you have to have a number of
different approaches way of answering
the same
the same question that's the key there
multiple approaches
when i start a school year the average
australian high school teacher has five
classes so that's
30 kids each 150 kids and you know one
of those 150
maybe 10 of them really will learn
exactly the way
you like to learn mr finally it's like
oh that made perfect sense the first
time
then there's the other 140 and they need
another way and they have different
questions that
you never asked as a kid but you've got
to anticipate those misconceptions so
you can help them is the way you present
yourself important like watching your
videos
you do look like a grown-up high school
kid in a way you dress like you're
wearing
you wear a kind of a shirt with a tie
and and sort of grey pants and all that
you do you do look is that a way of
relating to them to make them go oh
i'm not that different from you look
it's kind of funny that's a really fine
line you have to walk for example
i have this beautiful red tie that i was
given as a gift uh many years ago
which i am never allowed to wear at
school with a white shirt because a
white shirt with a red tie
is the boy's uniform in senior school so
it's kind of like that's off limits
someone's going to say hey young man
you're out of class you need to have you
got a pass to go to the toilet you know
so
i have to be careful with how i ride
that line it was only a couple of years
ago actually the first time
where i was at the year 12 former with
my students and i left and the security
didn't card me they didn't say hey
hey kids aren't allowed to leave yet
that was only a couple years ago the
first time that happened but
you do have to have that sense of
immediacy that you understand the kids
you're not their buddy you're not their
friend don't try to be cool that's
the wrong idea don't don't don't floss
or do a dance move in front of your kids
but
but you have to be able to understand
them when you started your
youtube channel youtube it was you were
making literature a video for one
student
you now have nearly 700 000 subscribers
but it was just one student to begin
with
what can you tell me about that
student's circumstances i mean
this student as you mentioned before he
was he was ill so he was diagnosed with
cancer and
it's kind of a standard issue did you
just say here's a textbook you know when
you
are away from school for the weeks of
your radiotherapy chemotherapy here's
the chapter you need to do
keep up with that and then when you
return uh we'll be up to here and you
can pick up where you left off no it's
asking a lot of the kid as well it's
asking a huge amount
and i remembered you know and this is
part of why again my mom didn't want
anyone to know
that she was ill part of the thing that
i think she was trying to avoid was
being
treated as different being you know
having
all of the teachers and your friends
look at you differently and i knew this
boy
part of what's troubling about having
your life uprooted and going with this
treatment is
you become your life gets defined by
this you don't get to do all those
things that you enjoyed before
so i wanted him to he enjoyed maths he
loved learning with us in class and i
wanted him to have access to that normal
life
he'd always had and this was part of how
i did it and how did you become where it
would become a thing
like these video these video lessons
were being shared and shared by lots of
kids within the school and then beyond
the school
yeah it was a couple of times so i think
one of the memories i had was
at my previous school when i started
doing these videos i was the touch
football coach so
i'd often take my team out on a bus we'd
go to another school or a public oval
and then the other schools team we'd
meet them then we'd play a game for now
and then we'd get back on the bus
i remember one time we got off the bus
and this team of girls who i was like oh
that's the right uniform we're playing
against this team
and they looked over at us which is
normal they're like oh there's the team
we're playing
but then suddenly a few of the players
on the team they kind of
nudged each other and they sort of
whispered and they were sort of looking
at me funny and i thought what's this
about and when i got closer they were
like
oh my gosh are you eddie wu and it's
never just eddie or mr it's always the
full name it's like are you ready
and i'm like yes they're like you're
that math teacher on youtube and i'm
like
yes i'm like how do you even know about
that and so i think that was probably
the first moment that i realized
this has gone way beyond what i
originally intended and even now like
i'll be in an
international airport i was in i was in
dubai airport on the way back from
uganda i was in taiwan
and it's kind of people will recognize
me and look look i i'm pretty
you know transparent about this asian
thin face glasses i have a pretty common
face i'm like are you thinking i'm
someone else but no
they're like i've seen your videos on
youtube we'll take a selfie it's lovely
it's very it's very cool it is lovely
that's
it's absolutely delightful so then then
suddenly this
the mass audience found it do you run
ads on your youtube channel
i don't run ads you'd make a lot of
money if you did
you'd make a real lot of money well i i
disabled them for a couple of reasons so
the first one is you know well
firstly um as distinct to other people
on youtube who it's their business
i have a job i'm a teacher i'm still in
the classroom it's one of the thing that
i love most i have a salary from the new
southern department of education
so i don't need you know revenue from
there to function but the other thing is
you know i'm thinking okay you're a 14
year old kid
and you have your phone and you can look
up anything you like
on youtube you could look like cat
videos you could watch
last week tonight with john oliver you
could be watching music video whatever
and instead instead you choose
voluntarily
to watch videos about maths the last
thing i want to do
is say i'm going to put an ad in front
of you wait five seconds before you skip
this i want to say
good on you for taking the initiative to
learn this yourself i want to say thumbs
up
so you won't thrust a travago ad in
front of someone instead you want to put
pull out a chair and invite them to sit
down 100 it's extremely public spirited
of you to to do that and what a
marvelous thing it is and you've been
making a local hero uh in the australia
day awards in 2018
as a result of all this you were saying
in talking about the shortage of of
maths teachers and i'm not expecting
huge disagreement from you on this it
seems to me that
if you paid teachers more if we paid
teachers and
and more and valued the work they do
maybe even ask more of them for that
money that's being paid of them too then
a whole lot of those people who are
being attracted into engineering
and i.t and other other
industries might find themselves much
happier as teachers and might come
flooding back into teaching maths and
then we might get that kind of result
we're actually looking for down the
track
which is a more math literate population
absolutely and i mean i'm
i'm not it's it's not about lining
people's wallets uh there's this guy
named dan pink who's done all this
research into
what motivates people in in jobs you
know if you want to get people in a
certain career you pay them more and the
answer is
yes to a certain point when people are
engaged in a creative
pursuit which and teaching is a very
creative industry
it's it's not that you pay the more you
get better results you pay them until
the point that they don't need to worry
about their income and their money and
then once they don't have to worry about
it they can
focus on their job they can think i'm
not getting second best because i'm
choosing this career you know i live in
sydney
on a teacher's salary alone if it's a
single income family you can afford a
pretty decent cardboard box but it is a
cardboard box nonetheless
and you've got lots of teachers who out
of their own pockets are buying things
for their own classes for their students
i every year we'll have
you know a bunch of kids in our school
who can't afford a calculator which they
need it's essential not that it's that
expensive but they don't have the
disposable income for it but teachers
are putting their hands in their own
pockets to pay for this
all the time all the time and so what
you want is to say
for schools and for individual teachers
that we have the resources to allow you
to
in an unfettered way concentrate on
doing your job best and caring for these
kids is it worse in rural areas
in rural areas the main challenge is
that it's hard to have teachers out
there
who have the right qualifications and
who'll stay um it's fairly common for
teachers to go out there for maybe
uh two or three years but then they
leave and and that's kind of
fatal you know because teaching so much
about relationships
you really it takes those three four
five years to become part of the
community know the kids their parents
and that investment is difficult to ask
of someone who's come from a city or
metro area suburban area
and to move out there relocated their
life so those areas are really difficult
to start and they're doing it tough
you're a real advocate for public
education have you ever been tempted to
go into the private school system which
would pay you i assume
more money than you get now yes
significantly more i've been
you know kindly uh invited offered
positions here and there
but for me even though i think that the
work that gets done in any school
private or public is is wonderfully
important and worthwhile
for me number one i always went through
public schools and i view it as
a public good education even if i didn't
have children of my own
it is a wonderful thing to live in a
society where we value
the education of our young people so
much that we say you know what we don't
want you to pay for this
this is something that we want you to
have that we're going to say it's
illegal not to send your children to
school
because it serves everyone all society
and culture
benefits and it's something i love being
a public educator saying
you know what in this classroom not a
single one of you pays
for the education you're getting in fact
the only person in this room that pays
is me because i'm a taxpayer
but it's worth it for the benefit you
get as an individual and that society
gets as a whole what a wonderful thing
eating and what a pleasure it is to
speak with you thank you so much
my pleasure richard thanks abc.net a u
slash
conversations is our website i'm richard
fiedler thanks for listening
[Music]
you've been listening to a podcast of
conversations with richard feidler
for more conversations interviews please
go to the website
abc.net.au conversations
discover more great abc podcasts live
radio
and exclusives on the abc listen app